i did it once it's it's warm water
usually your pants are off i jacked off
into one they never
rotation
back off my broccolini
uh we we caught you in uh theo on cam
talking before the show
and then ye you admit you've been
waiting you've been dating someone
yeah it's just fresh unreal
you son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] mine right
now my calling is
[ __ ] mine oh my god see how things
work
yeah see how i love y'all you think i
was some peasant off the street
who couldn't [ __ ] get girls you told
me man
[ __ ] you i got so much [ __ ] in the
weekend
i could have a little baby on the way i
could have a little
baby all the way [ __ ] you guys
okay you told me you guys i got girls i
got a girl
i got a [ __ ] girl stevie
where's that we need to delete the
energy
he he he he he honeydicked us
no before the show he accosted me about
this information
that's new to me i was i was in the
bathroom i got here late i see that
i didn't i'm disappointed i didn't know
you guys were filming
that we're always filming it's okay i'm
glad we caught that but i was just
trying to help you
find a girl i wasn't trying to like
think about the thing about the girls
last week who
submitted videos and now they're seeing
this like oh he's he's a [ __ ]
pussyhound
yeah he's a he you have a hickey on your
neck dude you guys are
[ __ ] slicksters we're good aren't we
[ __ ]
yeah oh my gosh you tell us
how the [ __ ] am i gonna
[ __ ] like i'm like hugh hefner right
there
well that's what you said i know but i
didn't think you guys were filming it
we're always filming daddy oh unreal how
disappointed are you theo
oh i didn't expect this you're gonna be
this this move this curveball you know
what maybe i was pulling your leg
that hickey does begs the differ on your
neck now show the camera that hit
because i was
because i was getting low bald and you
know it was like a make-a-wish
foundation
and i just kind of concocted this story
mobile
uh i concocted the story of i thought
you were getting no balls dude
i thought we were trying to i was blue
this is very deceptive
what you guys that was crazy you guys
did that no you did
what do you mean i did that i didn't
think y'all were filming it was just
between me and theo
i wasn't filming nick was filming first
of all and i did think it was just
between us
yeah i did it
that's how much money brent brennan has
he just valets his own car
correct literally pulls up at his house
puts on the jacket gets out
and hands the keys to himself yeah dude
that's the level i'm at
but what i don't know if you have a
hickey on your neck but my thing is this
is what i thought i didn't think
we were i i thought we were trying to
help you find a decent gal hey this
happened just recently guys it's not
like every week i have a date you know i
did a little i was just really i was i
was hype
i was hyping it up okay i'm normally a
lonely guy
okay you sound like a playboy but uh
your handlers
i just got lucky recently i met a real
nice cute girl
and that's all i made let's go back to
that footage it seemed a little like you
were
no but you know that wasn't supposed to
be shown and i you know i apologize for
being that um
brash yeah braggadocious about it and
everything so
god that hurts me man just watching it
i'm so sorry
see i'm blowing his [ __ ] mind right
now
he's [ __ ] mine oh my god see how
things work
see how i love y'all you think i was
some peasant off the street
who couldn't [ __ ] get girls you told
me man
i got so much [ __ ] in the weekend i
could have a little baby on the way
i could have a little baby all the way
guys i got a [ __ ] girl's name
there is no baby come on harris going to
take care of that kid of yours
funded thing and i'm really
usually not that confident just hear me
out i didn't realize you guys were
capturing that
and i apologize so you know reality kind
of
set in you know what the reality is
what's on your neck bubba
it's just yeah this is a wrestling like
me and jeremiah were wrestling
and i'm not buying that wrestling with
each other's mouths
because i talked to your handler out
there and he said you flew a little
philly dove down that you met on
instagram she's from washington
stayed the night with a couple nights
what did you just say first of all greg
is his handler's name
craig it's craig yeah greg my buddy
craig out there said you flew this
little philly dove down from washington
you met on instagram i don't know what
you're talking about man really i don't
know where you're getting your
information let's see what craig has i
apologize for that behavior
correct i apologize for that craig greg
on the mic
i apologize craig out there let's see if
he's been driving around
craig this is the moment of truth greg
be real with us where where
is this hickey come from my man i mean
uh steve told me he was from wrestling
he's a good friend what i'm saying he's
a good friend because he told me
wrestling something else me and jeremiah
we got into we tussled a little bit
on our last episode off camera we got a
little bit too physical
and uh that's how i got this map burn
and uh
yeah it's a it's a matte burn it is let
me see i know my way around a map
that's a hickey bubba no this is a
little young philly duff sucking on your
neck no that's
not what it is and uh i apologize let's
take that first part out
and uh i apologize i was being a little
braggadocious
no yeah but we but i don't understand
what really happened and i'm not trying
to put you on the spot i
i don't i want you to know that i we
legitimately were just trying to get you
a date
i appreciate it and like this yeah um
what theo said this morning
man i hope we find love for stevie
that's really sweet of you and i
really appreciate that really you said
that yeah he called me because man i
man i'm stressed are you way so stressed
dude show stand up
tv just nah hopefully find love for
stevie and then i see that
that's so that's so nice of you yeah and
so that was uncalled for
i've had those girls uh mandy uh amanda
margaret they've just been all week like
has he made a decision has he made a
decision do i
see now you guys are making it worse
you're playing with love you're playing
with people's hearts
it really is not love because i know the
entertainment there's entertainment
value in
all this as well so maybe i don't know
like i don't know
right maybe you're hiking i don't know
yeah i don't know if it comes from a
pure place that maybe they just want to
get a little
you know low sean i mean listen we like
entertainment but we also want you to
find love like i appreciate
what about the ladies what do we say to
the ladies that so so are you just are
you interested in one of the dates you
think you're not going to do it right
now
just give me some time to think about it
you know because it's all hitting me all
at once so
there's you know it's like a tidal wave
you know what i mean that's true and we
kind of
want to apologize for my behavior i
don't apologize yeah
we could have come on a little strong
man yeah no no we didn't make you feel
and you came from a good place well we
don't want you to feel like you're a
peasant either i can't get
[ __ ] as you said like that was uncalled
for again let's play it one more time i
just want to make sure we
want to recap exactly
and is that definitely stevie that looks
like tim pointing to the hickey
y'all you think i was some peasant off
the street who couldn't [ __ ] get
girls you told me yeah [ __ ] you
that's my favorite so much [ __ ] in the
weekend i can have a little baby all the
way
that's my favorite part okay
can i speak on my behalf that was
uncalled for that's really not me guys
that's really we've all been there steve
you know yeah we've all been there after
a couple grams of bloat you know
i'm proud of you man so i'm glad you got
a girl to suck on your neck
no it wasn't it wasn't that like that
was just i kind of over exaggerated as
well like me and jeremiah got into a
little tussle
and uh yeah and then that's how i got
the mark on my neck well jeremiah sounds
like a real dime i'll say that
i will say that speaking of german weird
name in washington what if we do this
guys because you know have you seen our
challenges
who's we you know because we we have
challenges on the scissor bros podcast
okay
what if we do bad good friends no no no
it's called the scissor bros now
we rebranded it i thought it was good
alphas versus betas
on our challenge me and jeremiah
i don't know ben gay on the nuts we've
done that before they're always
naked yeah we're naked a lot are you
guys in or what i think it'll make for
some good content
i'm leaking yeah my career is more where
i'm staying clothed i feel like you're
like
but ben gay canceled just on the nuts or
your butt
i'm fine i'm doing good yes i appreciate
it but what i do
you guys need views but but i mean it'll
just be a fun challenge what do you guys
think
i i don't think i would like to say no
immediately actually it's a heartbeat
for me too yeah guitar packs all right i
just thought i'd bring it up
no i think it's nicey though and it's
cool you guys do that
yeah now here's a fellow right here who
wants to date you so
so recently on our facebook group some
brave souls have uh
posted pictures of themselves asking for
people to roast them
and i reached out to them and we got
them to read their
their favorites now here's your chance
stevie also to pass this energy on you
know
i don't want you to feel like we're
upset at you do you feel like we're
upset at you
no i felt like i kind of let you guys
down though because that took a lot of
effort and research
on your guys's half and so yeah you guys
apart so i
when chin broke it broke our hearts at
least he waited till he went
on the date we went all the way didn't
have a lot of my things going on the poo
breath and the
dry skin yeah there's easily fixable
things all you have to do is go to your
hybrid
yeah weddings you're easily curable by a
trip to a cvs
okay like i love you is that true you
guys i would say yes
agree with theo science come a long way
with bad breath
i mean but but look it's not i know it's
not easy to go i felt like i let you all
down i'm sorry
oh man i'm glad you're okay having some
young philly suck on your neck
what's up king and the sting buzz buzz
gang gang so you start your online store
you're doing what you love selling
products people want
orders coming in fast now the hard part
shipping those products out
doing a timely fashion that's why you
need ship station they make it easy
right
shipstation is the number one shipping
software for e-commerce sellers with
more five-star reviews than anybody else
whenever you're shipping merch whatever
it is amazon etsy your own website
ship station funnels all your orders one
simple interface that you can manage
from anywhere even your freaking cell
phone
you can get access to amazing discounts
with major carriers including usps
fedex ups easy compare carriers and
choose the best solution
every time ship more in less time just
use the code kats to get a 60 day free
trial
that's two months free no hassle stress
free shipping just go to shipstation.com
click the microphone top the homepage
type in k-ats that's shipstation.com
enter the offer code cats makeship
happen
with your podcast listener and podcast
doer stand up comic overall badass you
build up an appetite you don't want to
stop
you don't prepare a meal that's where
grubhub got you covered man
grubhub works hard all right they work
hard to serve you
and they're giving you a special offer
right this offer is for panera
today grubhub's doing a little extra to
serve panera get free delivery perk on
your first order of panera
for 15 or more order through the grubhub
app or online grubhub
they serve restaurants i saw brett favre
at the seafood restaurant in our
hometown and it just comes up
and you just now tell us you saw that
was he in crocs
i didn't see his feet he had sensitive
gums though
oh wow what a legend he's a louisiana
boy right i saw brett favre
from mississippi we used to go eat
mushrooms and kill them we used to put
on
brett favre jerseys me and my black
friend would put on an um
i want to say it was a julius pepper but
it might have been somebody else's
friend put on a reggie white
um no i want to say it with julie's
peppers and we would get
mushroomed out and chase each other hell
yeah try and sack your butt
yeah no just like it was nothing sexual
we were just children and he was
straight and i was straight
that's fun times wow what a good time
but that was in brett favre's hometown
dude and then i saw him walking in the
seafood restaurant i walk
there's like you walk up to walk it's
like has one of those galley gangway
seafood restaurant style you know like
oh walk the plank in you know type of
thing
and off to the left there's a man
sitting there and it looked like brett
favre from the side i only saw about
25 of his face
and i'm walking in and the guy inside
like
knew me and said hey and uh and i said
is that brett favre sitting on the porch
because i used to work there i used to
smoke weed there and work there
and uh and he said yeah that's him is it
a joe's crab shack
no it's like called morton's steakhouse
but no see oh it's a steakhouse it's not
seafood it's not steaks
it's like water steak seafood how many
shrooms did you eat
um probably 30 grams a lot
that's that's a lot isn't it you beat an
insane asylum dude
that explains a lot what the hell i
remember playing against
a [ __ ] nickel defense for about an
hour
oh dude we had as many as you could as
the ground would make oh my oh so
they're fresh off the ground
fresh off the ground you don't [ __ ]
around oh you could smell the [ __ ]
you could smell the steak on them some
of them were medium rare
bro they were fresher than that thing on
your neck boy
dude were you seeing stuff oh dude yeah
that's all right
he thought he was being chased by reggie
white he was so [ __ ] hot aliens
wow what a reference i saw a lot rosie
but here we go this guy ended up in the
hospital trying to help you out stevie
let's hear more
okay yeah logan bertels he asked the
face
uh cats facebook fans to roast him they
lit him up
there were hundreds hundreds of messages
and he he read the best ones
hey what's up guys my name is logan i'm
from olympia washington
lifelong three white belt and
practitioner
of the dark cards here to read you some
rows from the king and the sting
facebook page
about me james buddilla says you look
like the victim and the child molester
at the same time though vance says you
look like the kind of guy that waves by
with both hands
[Laughter]
says you look like a second string
ultimate frisbee player
jared whip says you look like nate
diaz's little sister
joshua felling says you look like a guy
who puts giant speakers in his kia
sportage sean phelan says you look like
forrest griffin's gay little brother
daniel henke says you look like you make
animal crackers fight before you eat
them
daniel everyone does that my favorite
was from tyler
if he says down syndrome or not get it
fixed
shout out to riley you're hot gang gang
buzz buzz
amazing now a lot of people believe that
there's a correlation between the asian
community and ds people
whoa wow mythology i've also read those
facts yup can you google that what are
you doing right now chin
will you back me up dude let's see what
his guys are attacking us
what yeah no dude
but a lot of people say you guys are no
chin back me up dude
not that i know of no you guys read it
wrong
i mean do you know what i'm saying is if
you see somebody with ds
and i beat it and they i barely beat it
they said in our town i'm still fighting
it so you're saying
asian people look like we all have yes
no no no no
no let's we gotta let you guys i'm not
saying that at all
okay i'm saying when you guys see each
other is there any like kind of
a little bit of a wink like hey buddy
but brendan did look at one of our
pictures my friend's pictures and he
thought one of my friends
had a touch of it yeah just because the
way he looks
we have slided eyes sometimes i don't
even notice that wait wait wait wait
wait finish that thought
what were you gonna say it was a picture
of uh jyn's friend i thought maybe he
had a touch of it i don't know
a little splash of it he did really
think so
look here now just asking i don't know i
don't know but anyway i love what this
guy had to say yeah
like those are hilarious down syndrome
the diaz brother
yeah that's logan uh logan bertles who i
thought was logan bartels
different guy i was like if you want to
shout out the band feel free there's a
guy named evan bartels
in one band uh it's just him a solo
singer evan bartel
yeah he bartels yeah bartels and he
has a theme song on this this past
weekend i was like shout out the band
he's like what band one letter different
he's like
the lap band he just starts reading an
ad for lap band surgery
now stephen when you see that kind of
stuff and you see a man really embracing
some of the things that are troubled
with him
i love it yeah i love it love it yeah
that's
humility yep and uh we got one more this
is
this is me this guy looks wet hey what's
up guys
it is travis daggs from indianapolis
indiana today
i am going to read some of the best
roasts
of me from king and the sting fans
cameron
armitage says your face looks like a
sucker that was dropped on a hairy
carpet
bailin roger says you look like a blind
fedex guy
no wonder i still ain't got my [ __ ] it's
been two months
tyler griffith says you look like the
type of guy who asked for a girl's
number
just to get closer to her brother
cody byrne says you look like the kind
of guy that can stick a popsicle up his
ass and tell what flavor it is
true eric richie says you look like you
tried to grow a beard but forgot how
so you glued your father's chest hair to
your neck
beau vance says you look like the kind
of guy that walks into super cuts and
says
give me the usual michael christopher
says
you look like you bring your guitar to
the party travis burma
says you look like you're trying to
bring back axe body spray
taylor hank says you look like you close
all cupboards and doors with your hips
[Music]
and last but not least bj compton says
your smile says my teeth look like gang
signs
yikes you got the rats on the black belt
brendan
gang gang buzz buzz buzz young man
those are great yeah that's great and
that's brave to just do it like that
yeah and shout out i think it was travis
that
that started the whole thing uh which is
great so keep that going in those
facebook groups those are hilarious yeah
we'll reach out
love him yeah we need some ladies too to
put it in there huh yeah some ladies
put yourself out let's get big moose on
there let's get your old x moose on
there get craig to put himself up there
your driver oh
ass craig roast me your handler yeah if
he's down if he has the
thick skin for it you have a thick skin
get lit up like that
craig you down he's not in yes
yeah and craig does it and craig's
hospice worker what is it yeah how do
you know craig
wait wait that's my i've known him for
18. yeah sure yeah that's fine but why
is he just hanging out you've been in
hospice for 18 years
that's my buddy he just comes around
yeah that's my buddy right there
that's a loyal friend right there go
ahead craig
craig looks like he holds a boom mic at
a porno set look at him
beautiful and craig's an adult huh yeah
and
you boys 18 years yeah he's uh my
neighbor too
oh wow that explains a lot that's
you've known hospice yeah almost two
decades you keep saying stuff but it's
yes
he comes over and watches the fights
with you and shoot your shirt right yeah
we've watched ufc
craigslist no craig uh replace his
toilet paper i don't have any yeah craig
is a hospice man
[Laughter]
we told stevie there weren't any other
suitors for him but we actually did have
one more person call him out
uh you ready for this stevie yeah go
ahead i know you're and i want to check
in with you
are you doing okay right now yeah i'm
doing okay yeah i'm fine yeah we're glad
you're here man
i don't want to think we're attacking
you i just feel like no i appreciate it
yeah okay for sure for sure
oh he says dime okay that roy nelson
oh what's up stevie didn't see you there
it's george
i hope you're training for our match man
i know i am
i've seen you wearing that diaper on
scissor bros
i think that's because i'm about to
wrestle the [ __ ] out you man
trust me lil ray ain't gonna save you
from this one oh
man i know you're also called crazy
i'm gonna make 130 pound korean stir fry
out you man
oh
that mass lobby yeah oh yeah i don't
know what to say about that
yeah he's a big boy uh wow what's his
weight class
heavy but dropping fast dude i mean like
a twa flight yeah he's melting in front
of our eyes
he's that's because him getting in a
wrestling stance is
pretty yeah threatening there but that's
when you have to go low low single
single you know how to angle john smith
single oh dude he'll wear you like a
freaking
scarf oh no he'll wear you like a damn
ugg bro but once
if he gets a hold of me he gets on top
of you yeah there's no getting up from
that
hey what's up what's up george
hey how are you guys doing good just saw
the video man
you looking good dude looking tough man
looking real
tough yeah when stevie saw the video and
went man
[ __ ] no i didn't say that i respected it
no i didn't say he's lying to you
he's lying to you don't don't believe
him that's all right stevie's 1-0
against his oiled black ass
ouch okay buddy yeah i respect i like
the video you look like you're training
yeah i'm putting in some work yeah you
look like it yeah
how much weight have you lost big dog
i'm officially down 130 all together
wow and since the last time we talked to
3 19 this morning
3 19. looking lean dog
today today is officially my one year
into my weight loss journey
congratulations you look great
you're looking may 31st was my birthday
so i just turned 22.
life is looking beautiful yeah good for
you man literally
i'm talking to my [ __ ] role models
right now
there you go thanks jorgen how did you
yeah what does your life look like
differently like what is your i honestly
like if you think about just some of
your daily thoughts and stuff like that
how are some of those different from
what it was like a year ago just like
your average daily thoughts
well i mean besides with just the
pandemic
like when i would think about going out
anywhere anything that involved physical
exertion it would be
a hurdle it would be a challenge it
would be threatening you know
so now like i go out and i [ __ ] i
face the world
like even if i don't want to do it don't
isn't an option
the only thing i can do is do so we're
moving forward
oh yeah absolutely that's crazy man
that's powerful dogs that's cool man
we're proud of you big dog looking good
man
thank you so much you feel more
confident
yeah i mean i'm still looking like a
[ __ ] bag of milk right now
you can't do much about that all i can
do is [ __ ] and work my ass off that's
all i can focus on
that promo your personality is already
there though that promo was [ __ ] fire
yeah that was great thank you thank you
i heard that you guys needed a little
wwe
promo you know i had to give it my all
no that was great brother yeah you did a
great job man we're gonna figure out
with stevie two today how to uh arrange
this fight and get you guys on the mat
you know i want to see this thing to a
finale
steve stevie has a hickey on his neck no
no it's a it's a wrestling injury
but uh yeah i i i'm impressed with your
training you're wrestling with the
vacuum cleaner
i respect your training and what you're
doing brother keep it up yeah you're
doing real
i love and i respect you i love you dude
i love you so much
i'm going to [ __ ] you
we'll check in with you soon man we
appreciate you so much man we love you
going man keep it going
love you all right brother all right
gang man okay
wow look at him there look at him
look at george the animal style they
call them oh look at that stance man
that's really threatening that wrestling
stance
stevie now look here's it now here's
another what are you guys doing you guys
kind of
caught me off guard there too i think
you have an opportunity really to make
i think you can't make these women's
dreams come true but i think you can
make this guy's dream come true by
meeting this guy somewhere
and actually doing a mouse he's going to
get down to the weight he likes his only
motivation
eventually we can probably fly him here
nick do you think yeah i think so
and do it here yeah it's not my money
let's do it
i'll ref it and then just get a mat out
there
i don't know how big the mats have to be
do they have to be big brendan pretty
big he's a big boy should we get the
singlets like the whole outfit
he's a big boy we don't need it
we don't need like a uh what's that ship
called that's flat on the top
aircraft carrier aircraft carrier yeah
we don't need that brandon it's a damn
it's a man it's a human being no i know
22 22 22. yeah okay
if you guys want to do it i mean he
seems like a good kid and i feel like
maybe we could do a tag team you and
jeremiah versus him versus him and
shimagani if
you get ta tired oh yeah yeah i could
have jeremiah in
and trimagani who's that shinogami he's
a
street fighter street fighter
heavyweight street beefs yeah let's do
that like
can it ryu yeah yeah if ken we're the
tag team
and then can we get the singlets yeah
you keep going there but we can't do
that yeah
get the whole outfit custom-made we use
some scissor bros singlets
yeah whatever he wants to do i'm
bolstering the mexican dragon
the headgear yeah yeah what's going on
what are you guys doing now huh
this is about you're insatiable this
isn't about you okay this is flop my
aunt
from uh oh tick tock aunt
my name is courtney campbell and i'm
trying to flaunt my aunt
her name is rhonda help me rhonda
but she's more like a mom to me we're
from danville virginia here's some fun
facts
she's a hard-ass worker hell of a cook
she loves to have fun she likes concerts
traveling lake beach
getting down and dirty riding side by
sides out in the woods
she can tie a cherry stem with her
tongue
and she's about to be 50 this year so
be easy with her oh quick ps
gang gang buzz buzz what up theo
i'm single about to be 34 no kids never
married
and i'm a nurse practitioner why not i
love nurses
dude that's for you buddy uh i love
nurses
oh rhonda caught that duck and you love
duck korean
yeah well i don't know yeah i guess so
i'm not a big duck guy she seems fun
a little bit of morgan wallin baby oh
that's a jam
you know what the roommates home if i
know me
you know that song i love them yeah love
them
that's the best one that's rhonda help
me rhonda that's a milfoil i've ever
seen one oh wow from milfissippi dawg oh
yeah
you do ty's that cherry stem with her
tongue daddy oh
yeah that underground rail road boy you
know what i'm saying though
buddy
bro this is a great opportunity for you
man she's younger than you no this is
not this is not my
secret that's not my secret this is your
segment it's all about your segment no
this is your segment you never know when
you're going to find love stevie
flop my outfit but this is this is a
different segment
i'd be happy to uh i mean i don't know
who would best date who i think
to her style in this room i think
you're pointing to the wrong oh i was
gonna say stevie nick dated a
six-year-old uber driver once okay
and no shade i was the uber driver
[Laughter]
so i think nick that could be your type
do you feel that at all nick likes to
wrinkle huh
i'm in a happy
[Laughter]
this saturday ufc 263 and you want to
watch it and you want to make money so
you gotta head on over to draftking
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the ufc
all right in this weekend's fight they
have a special odd boost for you
guys and here's my picks this is a
parley you gotta pick all three
to win your bet boost your odds my picks
are izzy
figuerito and muhammad all to win their
fights
uh just head to the app now and find the
brendan shops pick under the odds boost
tab doesn't matter if you're new or
existing customer bet on it with my
three picks
you get your odds boosted right along
with your thick friend here
all new users download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app now
use my promo code all right uh cats when
you sign up bet on my parlay of fighters
to win you'll see it on the tab brendan
chob
to win saturday night for ufc 263 that's
izzy
muhammed figuerito boom special boost
just for you guys the sperm code kats
only at draftking sportsbook
the official sports been partnered with
ufc must be 21 or older in new jersey
pennsylvania indiana michigan and
virginia only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler
earn indiana 1 809 with it or in
virginia 888 532 3500.
uh yeah i know i'm a happy committed
relationship so
yeah no they just ran off of a card
that was a hallmark card dude no one's
buying that
uh so this guy's got to keep the old the
old big clutter over there and here's a
this dime is for y'all's bank baby okay
i'm sitting this one out
oh he's got a tattoo of bobby on his leg
what up brendan
what up do y'all got a king and are
stinging for you right here
in the uh harley's riding it some people
think it's old school and lame like the
old guys
wild hogs and then there's guys like us
oh damn always mike drifting on this
[ __ ]
wow is this uh hulk hogan's son
nate cogan yes
all year brendon let's go
i feel like he's gonna cry
[Laughter]
oh man that guy's like that guy's good
man
[Laughter]
that thick evil knievel on that [ __ ]
hog man
i hate the loud vehicle so man i hate
the lively eagles too yeah i can't stand
it
and now part of and i hate to drop in
the all culture again but i know you
guys are really
crosstalking i'm gonna say kawasaki or
something no i don't feel like that's
coming
i wouldn't say anything like that that's
idiot okay i'm just saying you guys it's
very popular to have some of these
mufflers
like this that was a huge deal for us or
not
yeah this is the asian community i mean
when we do our import cards i had it
like the honda civic super yeah super
loud muffler doesn't your brother have a
godzilla jeans
godzilla gtr yeah but those aren't that
loud they sound cool
they sound cool but we made it sound
loud as crap we took the catalytic
converter that's why he's going to see
that
yeah modifications yeah yeah
what is it that why is that part of a
thing like what is it
i don't even have a car i don't know i
have no idea why they do that
you don't just talk i have no idea you
just don't want to toss a spoil on that
next uber that picks you up you never
get that urge yeah
i would you would be the craziest asian
bro if you just brought your own
catalytic converter or your own spoiler
hooked it onto any uber that picked you
up
put a wing on that hyundai that's a lot
of work really that would be insane that
would be insane it would also be awesome
it would be awesome though where would
you get something if you go full
asian i don't know there's a kid i'm
sure straight bikes art store
there you go chin nose straight pipes oh
straight pipes we have a guy from the
zeta cartel calling huh yeah he's got
another king at her sting he's a
zookeeper from that place we almost
bought it
that was a bad idea shout out to the
gods theopatra
and brandon spending guap shout out to
the culture corner
kate and chapel and shout out to nick
and crimson chin
my name's hector you could say my last
name is iowa
i'm from denver colorado brandon know
what's up
and i have a king or stinky
so how do you guys feel about the dead
assuming the answer
now how do you feel about living in
front of the cemetery
wow oh no
would you guys have a problem living
near 100 plus dead people
are you guys not into ghost sex and all
that
look that's the original storage wars
man is uh
those type of deal the other day it's so
funny i saw a storage facility
next to a cemetery and it was just like
the craziest
uh
that's why i don't know any true
mexicans dude mexicans bro you'll wake
up in the morning you're mexican we're
gonna be out there talking to a ghost
bro they love if you go to el dia de los
muertos
they love uh they go to the cemetery and
party with them do dice do oranges eat
them drop those little orange
flower petals yeah you can hear them at
night shoot that six-pointer
yeah but there's ghosts huh that's like
150 ghosts
like near your house yeah but i think
you have a lot of stuff to blame stuff
on where's these young ghosts at man i
keep saying that
everyone gets talking about these old
ghosts where's the young ghost dad doug
that's true you never hear young kids
talking about ghosts anymore
never never yeah it's still that's true
king it i say king of man i like this
dead and i'm into that kind of stuff
that nostalgia that
uh human nostalgia you'd buy a house
next to a cemetery yeah
i love it i already found a place i want
to be buried man i was driving through
mississippi one time and there's a man
that was a darker man
and he was pushing a l he was wearing a
full suit
in like 92 degree sun pushing a lawn
mower
in this little cemetery and he i thought
he was it was like
it was almost like he was a ghost and
yeah that's a ghost i gotta be buried
there
i think so man unless i see a better
cemetery
hey keep your eyes open man yeah i i i i
like to go look at cemeteries and i like
to see cemeteries
memorial day weekend apropos there you
go did you go visit any of our fallen
soldiers
i didn't i didn't cook out anybody i
mean i grilled some burgers
i hung out with my step family and
they're they're gonna die
soon yeah i know you got step family
they're gonna die pretty soon
that's close but i think he was in the
service i think you have a stepdad
yeah i didn't know that you want to be
bare you don't want yours
you don't want like i'm not getting
creamed out dude what else gets creamed
like creamy
cremated berries spread my ashes over
laura canyon dog yeah
topanga canyon really in traffic or not
yeah it can be free
as you're sitting on traffic just toss
it inside yeah that'd be sick
lambeau field yeah oh for you lambo oh
damn look at this
fancy [ __ ] over here
man i just want love for you stevie i
don't want love for me really i think
the truth is i want love for me and i
just keep
projecting on steve because we need to
work on you we need to find some love
for you let me find your connection
yeah i'm thinking about going to like
one of those places you go to like
get focused on it you know oh there's
places like that
yeah like clinics or something bobby
member not rehab but let's like
wellness center center you maybe you'll
meet a little philly dove in the rehab
that ain't gonna help are you just going
back to om again
no orgasmic meditation that thing i got
bit by some lady's dog i was
fiddling over there what was that all
about is that a rehab it was hard
it was like this medication this
meditate this cult kind of deal where
they
the first time i went it was downtown
and
the main you go there and they had
coffee and everything a little couple
like snacks nothing heavy yeah
nothing like mostly fruit light some
light collages
anyway uh have you heard this brandon no
that he used to do this
but anyway so i went down there
bleachers 10 15 minutes into it they
somebody lays down on a table up front
naked
and a doctor gets up there kolaches
there you go there's a picture of them
on the right
those are kolaches just like breakfast
snacks treats oh those delicious
so anyway everybody's having their
little watermelon little kalachi and
then they say all right
you know bridgette's going to get up
here and spread them so next you know
you have a naked lady up at the front
right you just it's literally you think
you're going to be like buying real
estate
i'm assuming she's not attractive she
was this lady about a heavy
off rod no she's about an eight oh okay
no
really is this the girl that brought you
this is not the other brother the girl
that brought me was uh
a friend of mine that was in pee-wee's
big adventure and she's tommy pickles
and she does the voice of tommy pickles
she's in she died adventure is she mean
gene
no she's the woman dottie dottie dottie
oh oh that's
a great he spills all the potato salad
on her face though
from the from the bicycle store she
worked at the bike shop yeah they had
the eggs
yeah that's her she also turned a smelly
cat into a jingle
on friends he did she stole it from
phoebe she was like her
friend from the past oh interesting so
she brought you to this cult
so she take me over there there she is
and she's wondering does she look like
oh she looks good still oh yeah she's
dying she's
timed up daddy yeah yeah yeah she's
maintained oh yeah
she's like 50 oh 101 nations sure
at least these are 60s 101 dimensions
adventure was back in the day 59. it was
in 1959 the movie
and she was born on september 11th r.i.p
dude
so anyway let's keep it cruising here so
what happened was this
um so you go to the center then they
start touching the lady up front they
teach you how to do it
how to like basically pleasure the woman
this is insane
with your hand right they show you how
to do you put on gloves and you put on a
little bit of um
not like jet i'm not like preserves or
whatever lube yeah like lubricant
hy jelly so you get it on your hand
you start touching the lady and it's
like 15 minutes you have to go like a
certain program how you do it
ladies you touch the lady yeah
so then they have everybody in the class
you that's at the meeting you go up in a
line and they teach you how to do it on
the lady that's up there
right augustine to do what pleasure yeah
pleasure to lady
pleasure to lady on our privates yeah
what and was that the chat class you
only did
not jelly like professional jelly uh
yeah not like something you'd have at
breakfast yeah no no but like
jelly yeah yeah yeah yeah we're not
talking about peach preserves over here
i don't know where it was from but i
think yeah it could have been kentucky
man but we had it so anyway
you have the you have the jelly yeah so
then they then they partner you up with
different people in groups of two
and you do you do the whole ceremony
again on the woman then
what about the guys the guys there's no
pleasure for the guys
i'm out i don't be in this cold well
that's part of you stay in because you
want to stay in brendan
so what's the whole point of that the
whole point of it is you learn how to
pleasure women
and then you start getting this
confidence that you know how to pleasure
women like a g
what insane that's [ __ ] insane i'll
tell you that's the name of the cult
huh it was called orgasmic meditation
but here's the crazy part then you're
part of a song called mickey mouse kids
club
what's wrong with you this is insane
then the guys just have blue balls yeah
kind of but then you start meeting up
then you're then there's weekly meetups
all over the place are you in your
underwear
huh no the man is fully clothed up the
woman is naked
it's also called spearmint rhino
that's right that's right i chewed gums
when i was before but
yeah usually i would just go in there to
start with candles what is it like
huh no sometimes eyes shut one of the
brothers sometimes would try to turn
some music on or something are you
wearing cloaks
one of the brothers start beatboxing
are you wearing cloaks and is there like
a whole like
witchcraft it sounds awkward as [ __ ]
it's pretty awkward but then you start
going to these meetings dude then
there's meetings all over every night
all over places people just meet up and
where where are they meeting now you're
on lincoln on lincoln boulevard
jesus crazy party
so you guys should be talking to him
about this stuff
oh homeless somebody's doing it oh this
guy
jumped in he started coming to the one
on lincoln
[Laughter]
because the door was just a word yo he's
just wandering by
he was like i like [ __ ] wow
totally so that's exactly how he got in
there oh they had a homeless killed the
food man
he needs to wash his hands oh he smelled
the collages oh yeah
you know he smelled that kentucky jelly
baby
hold up i think you're missing certain
parts so is she missing
not being that detailed
you think i don't play y'all's game here
i get
listen there's a line a single file line
yeah
20 guys in suits no that's gangbang what
is going on dude you went to a gang bear
an organized game where you're confusing
with
peach yours sounds like an audition for
the matrix too
dude we're talking about something
different no that's the same thing
we're talking about the same thing no
we're not yeah we are
you said that many people have never
been talking about the same way
men in suits single file line candles
ky jelly and a naked woman am i right
and how many times do you do this
no once you that's the original meeting
once you go to the the the uh weekly
meetings
you wear whatever you want and they just
pair you off in a man woman group that's
insane
is there a shrine you have to bring your
own blanket so it's byob yeah
is she on like an altar like what she's
like you lay down these blankets and
pillows
can you be under the influence like
could i be seven bears deep in that
[ __ ]
you can but i would i would do a mint if
you do that is it dark in the room
no it's pretty well lit it's insane and
she's doing
naked she's [ __ ] like 20 women in the
meeting so still many women are butt
naked you're all
naked wait a minute there's more than
one woman oh i see now i'm confused man
you put this guy in image here we go huh
here we go let's see an image right
there there's steel
theo there we go which one let's see uh
oh that's cool what's going on there
it's from a movie
cat's in the wild yeah that's cats in
the wild
and i'm the guy right there in the green
shirt that's
vince vaughn yeah i'm vince vaughn
that's from couples therapy are you
wearing basketball shoes
you wearing basketball shorts there you
go that's exactly what it's like
what are you what is he doing that's
that's that's that's what gadget
meditation that guy's elbows
deep in somebody's head i think i'm
watching yes yeah
and that guy wasn't ready like i'm not
ready yeah this is basically
what's just right hand doing huh how
many times
how many times did you go through until
he got bit by a dog yeah i went about 15
times then i went to this lady's house
and her dog
bit me on the alarm
what kind of dog was huh bichon it was
like a bichon frise yeah
there you go but it was older though it
started to get brown around the head why
did the dog bite you this is
now it obviously got a little uh more
intimate if she invited you to the house
because it's probably frowned upon
yeah no it's not frowned upon it's it's
actually encouraged to meet up with
people whenever you can
insane so do you take it further than
no i never took it any further man we
could some people might i think there's
some people and they're looking to take
things first
you touch the breasts too or no it's
just the lower part shirt stays on only
pants and underpants come off
and then just her vagina yeah
that's it that's it that's it insane and
then you have
jelly in your hand in your fingers if
you want to bring some yeah or they have
some
and then how long are you i'm sorry for
doing this no it's interesting i forgot
about it but are you doing
are you doing this if you want no you
don't you don't know there's only one
move you can do they teach you how to do
well
show us i'm not showing it no just just
just do it just do it
you got to take the class [ __ ]
huh
these are secret techniques just do it
do the cobra kai
huh is it a cobra kite like like a cobra
cl
is it like no it's not like that it's
like a uh
it's kind of like a it's kind of based
on the thumbs up
oh it's a thumb move i would say it's
loosely based on a thumbs up
did you learn anything brandon it's kind
of like a thumbs up and then it comes
hey buddy come over here
so it's you jam your thumb no come on
see that's why i don't want to do it
you're in hospice i know but thumbs okay
you're living without cancer in hospice
all right
so thumbs up then come over here
oh that's what you mean oh okay i get it
i get it i get it
it's a lot of like thumbs up like this
like at the end you feel like you could
be a crossing guard for like mike
i got it i got it i got it i understand
now this guy's got a king at her stick
it
just get me out of this conversation
okay sorry
are you that's what i want to know are
you
have you ever been have you ever been a
guy who's just oh my god is that boring
what the hell is that he said float pots
i did it once it's it's warm water
usually your pants are off i jacked off
into one they never
rotate you jerked off i did man
you nutted i never got invited back yeah
isn't it salt water
it is man it's warm water just floating
there with your dick out yeah and then
you jerked off
oh yeah i apologize there's a filter
system in there though so don't be weird
right but you nutted in the water i mean
no i mean
how come you guys are closing down i'm
i'm talking about my dry nuts and you
guys won't even talk about jerking off
in a flow tank
i didn't do it i know but i'm asking 15
times
yeah but i did it it was registered it
was organized this was a sanctioned
event
he's the one who's just he's just doing
that on his own
and then and then they go just take your
pants off so the next thing i'm floating
in this warm water in the dark
but you use your imagination how did you
you just used your mind
oh yeah you're out here freebasing your
own dna into this float tank
the name of the place but he did buy the
jacket which matches the float tanks are
you naked
unbelievable yeah so you're floating
floating naked nothing to do
wow it's scary in there right yeah not
for me
yeah that's the crazy thing a lot of
times when guys have nothing to do they
will
masturbate yeah i got very bored yeah oh
it's about a show later that night
at the cubs it's the best you played the
cubs
cobbs at cobb's yeah oh i will never
masturbate during the day i pro
i don't even like to masturbate during
the week good for you for putting
yourself out there and learning how to
get it done well here's what happened i
want to tell you guys some of the
experience that i had that i had was
you start to feel because you start to
learn how to pleasure women
the right way the right way what is this
called chin
gesticulatively you learn how to
pleasure women's
just gesticulate with your appendages so
then and next time when you look at a
woman bro you know in your head that
you confidence oh dog you were like well
what about your tongue
huh why are you getting that out
i just but you know what i mean and
there's dave portnoy doing it
and there's a woman damn damn old flat
face
these ladies getting diced up
all right
[Laughter]
what's going on bro my girls made no
sound one woman
fell is that what it's like is this
actually that guy clearly has his black
belt whatever that thing
is yeah you really did this man oh i was
yeah i'm a one year member did you
remember this community
i was they got busted why did you get
out huh why did you get out
honestly dude too much time there was uh
there was at one time when i went to the
place over on lincoln there was two
homeless dudes [ __ ] beefing in there
after one of them had pleasured like a
woman
in the thing dude and i'm like and
and people you know it's l.a so you
don't want you like you don't want you
can't call somebody home
and i'm like this guy has oscar the
grouch gloves on his hands
and he's touching your vagina and you're
not going to call them homeless
you're an idiot yeah you will find out
about the deal
literally the doors open
bro oh the jelly bro you smelled it
you're right you smelt it bro it's the
reason why they even
have doors on stuff is to keep homeless
people out yeah yeah especially down
there off lincoln
you think i'd have fun there oh you
would be i'd be the king down there oh
you'd be the oksana biola
yeah you'd thrive you would be the uh
you'd thrive down there doug i would
thrive you know you'd be the tristan
yamaguchi or whatever of it yeah
i do well the olympics christiana yes
you'd be the germany lana there you go
right there that's me
oh yeah you're getting murdered by your
brother
oh my god if me and bob went there
well if you go make sure you document it
for us yeah
so you're not gonna go on a date but
you're going to fight george is that
where we're at
i think so we just want to make sure
that you want to do something stevie
we want to help no i appreciate it all
we're doing is trying to help theo's had
experience in that amount of work
yeah but you know i met a gal that i
like and stuff i don't know what's
happening it seems like she liked you
sucking on that neck
well you just had to tell us that man
i'm glad you uh we just wanted you to
find somebody it didn't matter
it doesn't matter who it is i wanted to
set up where because it's it's ironic
right like we did that and then this one
is way different
yeah just i want to make it different
right nick yeah yeah just to have a
different
kind of flow to the the podcast we love
you man
oh yeah figure it out look man thanks
for having me man yeah it's fun man it's
fun
thanks for sharing your story too yeah
yeah you're welcome man um
now you guys sure you want to show that
footage at the beginning or you could
show it
again at the end if you want no no no no
i don't want to see it
it sounds sounds like we'll just play it
out we'll close it out i'm in oklahoma
city tonight brickstown comic club
thursday friday saturday get your
tickets love you guys man love you too
man and uh
i'm gonna be at
i got tickets going on sale right now
and uh they're at theovonne.com
tour and that's st louis cincinnati
charlotte durham chattanooga knoxville
wilmington uh wilkes bar
and uh some other places charleston
richmond albany
buffalo columbus and minneapolis but i'm
excited man so go check it out
theovan.com
tour and thank you guys as always for
your support and uh
stevie man we want to we just we love
you man i love coming here
let's close it out with this video yeah
no no you guys don't have to do that
again he showed it twice already
cut his mic well we showed it three
times
i got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think
i am in flow black rifle coffee i'm
ready to go i need a sponsor i am a
monster about to open up with this at my
concerts flow is contagious browser
outrageous thicker than girls that are
instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey
diaz meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you